[Music]  our son Billy is doing very well he's  good Jimmy Kimmel returned to his  hosting duties Monday night after  spending a week off with his newborn son  who's recovering from heart surgery the  49 year old comedian gave an update on  his little ones health and shared this  adorable video my wife took a little  video of him today you can see there he  is he's smiling he's getting bigger  he's sleeping while he can read now  which they say just last week Jimmy  reveals in an emotional opening  monologue  the couple's bundle of joy has  congenital heart disease  poor kid this is what he looked like on  Monday but this is what he looked like  yesterday  [Applause]  Jimmy's wife Molly shared this sweet  snap to Twitter of the father-son duo  cozied up together in the hospital she  sweetly captioned the pic I am thankful  to love and be loved by these two brave  guys both Criers  [Music]  you